[Music]
hi everyone i'm haley and this
is waking up with elle and this is oscar
hayley bieber taking viewers through her
morning routine for elle magazine
every day that i know i'm gonna wake up
and it's gonna be the same thing
i think helps me feel like there's like
stability in my life and stability
around me i'm always going to wake up
and brush my teeth and wash my face and
make a coffee before i leave the house
she also stuns on the april 2021 cover
of the mag
inside she explains what it was like to
marry her hubby justin bieber at such a
young age
she was only 21 when they tied the knot
in 2018.
she says she was insanely young and that
it almost sounds
ridiculous when you say it out loud but
she adds quote
i do think for somebody like me and
somebody like justin
it's different we've seen a lot for our
age we have both lived enough life to
know
that's what we wanted it's a good part
and i love him haley also gets candid
about how hard it is to live such a
public life
revealing quote in the beginning of our
marriage i just wanted to hide i was
like
i don't want people so in my business
she also adds that she sees forever with
justin and
isn't afraid to put in the work
admitting they definitely have
little fights but always prioritize
their marriage
she adds quote i think any relationship
can fail hollywood or not
is it harder in the public eye
absolutely but i think the two of us are
grounded by our faith
i'm not saying it's this easy peasy
thing that doesn't take work
we talk to a therapist we do what we
have to do
what if you had it all but nobody to
call
[Music]
this all comes as a source tells et the
lonely singer has been working hard to
finish his album
justice out march 19th quote haley has
been super supportive
understanding of him and right by his
side especially when he has felt
overwhelmed or anxious
she has always been his rock and he has
always been her protector
the source adds they look forward to
expanding their family one day and are
excited to see
what the future holds